On fait tous beaucoup trop d'erreurs qui
tuent notre iPhone.
Je sais que vous adorez votre iPhone.
J'adore également mon iPhone.
Si on n'a pas envie qu'il finisse à la
poubelle,
il faut faire extrêmement attention à nos
usages.
Même s'il est résistant, même s'il n'est
pas fragile.
Vous allez voir qu'on fait tous ces 7
erreurs.
On pourrait très facilement les éviter
pour ne pas raccourcir la durée de vie de
notre iPhone.
Allez, c'est parti !
Première erreur, vous rechargez votre
iPhone lorsqu'il est mouillé.
Alors je sais, votre
iPhone est certifié être résistant à
l'eau et à la poussière, IP68, il n'y a
pas de problème, il peut tomber dans de
l'eau.
On ne va pas se baigner avec, non.
Mais il peut tomber dans l'eau, piscine,
baignoire, n'importe où, vous le sortez,
et tout ira bien.
Mais il y a une erreur qu'on fait et il
faut faire extrêmement attention...
Laissez-lui le temps de sécher, puisque
votre iPhone ne va pas aimer qu'on vienne
le brancher, lui apporter de l'énergie
alors que ses connectiques sont encore
mouillées.
Donc, attendez quelques heures qu'il soit
réellement sec ou alors faites une
recharge sans fil, auquel cas vous
n'aurez pas de problème.
Sinon, faites vraiment, vraiment,
vraiment attention.
Soyez très vigilant à ne pas venir
recharger votre smartphone lorsqu'il est
mouillé ou encore humide, tout
simplement...
Deuxième erreur qu'on fait quasiment
tous, on laisse recharger son smartphone
toute la nuit.
Alors je sais, c'est très pratique.
Le soir, vous vous reposez, vous le
prenez, vous le branchez, vous le déposez
sur un chevet, vous êtes tranquille.
Comme ça, vous vous levez le matin, il
est chargé à 100 % et tout va bien.
Mais en réalité, c'est une très mauvaise
habitude qui va dégrader de façon
prématurée votre batterie et réduira,
bien évidemment, sa durée de vie.
Donc, ne faites pas ça.
Non.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe lorsque vous le
laissez charger ?
Bien que les smartphones soient
aujourd'hui plus intelligents et arrivent
mieux à réguler leur charge, mais pour
autant, lorsqu'il est chargé à 100%, il ne
va jamais descendre, il va descendre un
peu, il va se recharger, il va se
recharger en permanence.
Ce n'est pas bon.
Ce qui est privilégié, c'est de venir
recharger son smartphone entre...
20 à 80%, on ne le laisse pas charger
jusqu'à 100%, on ne le fait pas descendre
en dessous des 20% et vous ne le laissez
pas se recharger toute la nuit.
Il faut imaginer la batterie de votre
smartphone un peu comme une éponge,
c'est-à-dire que plus vous allez venir
l'utiliser gorgée d'eau, enlever toute
l'eau, se gorger d'eau à nouveau,
elle va s'abîmer et s'user.
Ainsi vous n'aurez plus une capacité de
batterie qui sera à 100% mais qui va
descendre très rapidement et arrivera
rapidement en dessous de 80% et à ce
moment là, votre batterie
ne tiendra pas très longtemps et ça,
c'est mauvais.
Au lieu de venir le charger toute la
nuit, ce qu'il faut faire régulièrement,
c'est faire des petites sessions de
charge rapide.
Lorsque la batterie arrive aux alentours
de 20%, un peu avant 20%, vous le
rechargez un petit quart d'heure, vous
allez remonter rapidement le niveau de
votre batterie et là, vous serez
tranquille.
Petite astuce, je le branche le soir sur
mon chevet, je le laisse remonter jusqu'à
à peu près 80%, je le débranche, je le
laisse tranquille la nuit et si je vois
que la journée j'ai besoin, je le branche
un quart d'heure c'est suffisant et je
suis tranquille.
Troisième erreur qu'on fait quasiment
tous, je la fais, je pense que vous devez
la faire vous aussi, on éteint jamais
notre iPhone.
Vous n'éteignez jamais votre iPhone ?
C'est vrai parce que votre iPhone est
extrêmement résistant et endurant.
On pense tout le temps qu'il va bien,
qu'il n'y a aucun problème.
Dites-le moi en commentaire, est-ce que
ça ne vous n'est pas déjà arrivé d'avoir
une panne bizarre ?
Un truc que vous n'expliquez pas, qui
n'existait pas avant, qui vient
d'apparaître et vous pouvez faire tout ce
que vous voulez, toutes les manipulations,
vous n'arrivez pas à régler ce problème.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Votre
iPhone
a besoin de faire une remise à zéro,
d'être éteint.
Comme vous vous dormez la nuit.
Il a besoin aussi
de fermer un peu les yeux et de se
reposer.
Lorsque vous allez avoir quelques petits
problèmes un peu bizarres que vous
n'arrivez pas à régler, éteignez votre
iPhone.
Ça lui fera du bien et ça pourra corriger
quelques petits bugs que vous ne saurez
pas expliquer autrement.
Je vous recommande de l'éteindre au moins
une fois par semaine.
C'est bien de le faire.
Vous l'éteignez, vous attendez à peu près
une petite minute, vous le rallumez et
c'est reparti...
Quatrième erreur.
Celle-là, elle est incroyable.
Ça m'est arrivé, j'imagine que ça vous
arrive aussi.
Votre iPhone, vous le laissez à côté de
vous à la plage.
Lorsque vous êtes au bord de la piscine,
vous êtes sur le sable chaud, vous posez
votre iPhone en plein soleil.
Et ça, c'est une très mauvaise idée.
Très mauvaise idée.
Votre iPhone est fait pour être utilisé
dans un intervalle de température allant
de
0°C jusqu'à plus 35°C.
Pas en dessous
des 20°C et pas au-dessus de 45°C.
L'idéal c'est entre 0°C et 35°C.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer si vous
laissez votre iPhone trop longtemps au
soleil ?
Il va
surchauffer, vous pourrez vous retrouver
avec un message sur votre iPhone qui dit
l'iPhone a besoin de refroidir avant de
pouvoir être réutilisé.
Il a eu trop chaud, tout comme vous, vous
pouvez avoir trop chaud au soleil, sauf
que lui, c'est une machine électronique,
il a besoin de vous pour être remis à
l'ombre.
Ce que je vous conseille très
concrètement ici, c'est lorsque vous allez
au soleil à l'extérieur, qu'il fait...
très chaud.
Déjà, vous évitez de le mettre dans le
sable parce qu'il ne va pas aimer.
Mettez-le dans un sac, que ce soit à la
plage, au bord de la piscine, en terrasse.
Comme ça, il ne va pas surchauffer et il
vous remerciera.
De la même manière, lorsque vous allez au
sport d'hiver, au ski ou que sais-je
encore, vous ne le laissez pas dans la
neige, dans la glace.
Il n'aime pas ça.
Vous le mettez au chaud, une petite
polaire, une petite laine...
Et il vous remerciera.
Dernière petite astuce à laquelle on
pense pas nécessairement.
Ne laissez pas votre
iPhone en plein soleil dans la voiture en
été.
Il va chauffer également.
Il ne va pas aimer.
Sur la route des vacances, ne le mettez
pas au soleil.
Mettez-le à l'ombre.
Globalement ne laissez pas votre iPhone
en plein soleil.
Il n'aime pas.
Non.
Cinquième erreur qu'on fait beaucoup
trop, c'est qu'on ne vient pas protéger
son smartphone.
Alors, je sais, je l'aime.
Il est beau, il est doux.
J'adore cet arrière et je dois
reconnaître que franchement, Apple fait un
très joli design et ça marche vraiment
bien.
Sauf que votre iPhone a beau être
extrêmement résistant avec tous les
matériaux de qualité que met Apple à
l'intérieur.
A un moment, lorsqu'il chute de façon
répétée, sur des gravillons, il n'y a pas
de magie.
Il risque de se casser, que ce soit
l'écran ou la face arrière...
Personne n'a envie d'avoir un écran qui
soit endommagé, qui soit éclaté et qu'on
devrait faire réparer, qui va vous coûter
de l'argent.
Et personne n'a non plus envie d'avoir un
dos de smartphone complètement rayé avec
plein d'impact ou encore pire, des
objectifs qui sont abîmés.
Je l'ai vu trop souvent, ça m'est déjà
arrivé.
Faites vraiment attention, venez protéger
votre smartphone avec une coque.
Pourquoi pas mettre une protection
d'écran ?
Ça ne coûte pas cher, on verra un peu
moins bien son design.
Mais on peut toujours trouver des coques
très jolies.
Pourquoi pas une coque à votre effigie ?
Sixième erreur, je suis sûr que vous
l'avez déjà faite, ça m'est déjà arrivé.
On ne fait pas de mise à jour sur notre
iPhone et il faut faire les mises à jour
qu'on nous propose sur notre iPhone.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'au-delà de rajouter quelques
fonctionnalités intéressantes, dans le cas
d'iOS 17 avec toutes les nouveautés qui
sont arrivées, c'est vrai que ça ouvre des
horizons et c'est intéressant, mais
régulièrement Apple apporte des mises à
jour de sécurité qui va
protéger votre smartphone.
C'est un vrai jeu entre les développeurs
et de l'autre côté des hackers, des
pirates qui veulent s'en prendre à vous.
Certes pas tout le temps, ils ne vous
courent pas derrière.
Mais il faut vraiment faire les mises à
jour pour éviter toutes ces failles de
sécurité qu'on ne connaît pas, qu'Apple
découvre et corrige pour protéger la
sécurité en ligne de ses utilisateurs.
Et c'est extrêmement important.
Donc faites attention...
Même lorsque votre iPhone est ancien,
tant qu'Apple vous propose de faire des
mises à jour, pensez réellement à faire
des mises à jour sur iOS.
D'ailleurs, c'est valable également sur
iPadOS, sur MacOS et sur tous les OS que
vous allez avoir.
Comme ça, pas de mauvaise surprise.
Votre iPhone reste à jour.
Vous avez de nouvelles fonctionnalités.
Ça sera plus compliqué pour les pirates.
Et ça, on aime...
7ème erreur, vous ne mettez pas un code
de sécurité suffisamment important,
suffisamment sécurisé.
Je vois encore des gens qui mettent 0 0 0
0 ou alors 1 2 3 4.
Il ne faut surtout pas faire ça.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que les iPhones sont des
smartphones qui sont énormément volés, où
il y a un vrai business derrière.
Faites très attention, si quelqu'un vole
votre iPhone, qu'est-ce qu'il va faire ?
Il va regarder si le code est 0, 0, 0, 0
ou 1, 2, 3, 4.
Comme ça, en plus de vous avoir volé
votre iPhone, il aura peut-être accès à
vos informations confidentielles.
Et si vous avez Apple Pay, à vos moyens
de paiement.
Donc faites extrêmement attention, soyez
très vigilants.
Ne mettez pas 0, 0, 0, 0.
Ne mettez pas 1, 2, 3, 4.
Soyez inventif au niveau du code.
Non pas pour moi, mais pour vous, pour
venir réellement vous protéger.
Parce que je connais déjà beaucoup de
personnes qui un jour l'ont regretté.
Et ça, c'est dommage.
Allez, je donne quelques petites astuces
en plus pour bien utiliser son iPhone et
éviter de le tuer.
Ne mettez pas votre iPhone
systématiquement en mode économie
d'énergie.
C'est vrai qu'on va se dire: "non mais
moi, je veux garder ma batterie le plus
longtemps possible".
Quand on achete un smartphone premium qui
coûte quasiment, voire un peu plus de 1000
euros, on veut l'utiliser...
à 100%.
Lorsque vous le mettez en mode économie
d'énergie, certes, l'autonomie sera
prolongée, mais vous allez vous priver de
fonctionnalités extrêmement intéressantes.
Premièrement, la luminosité sera baissée
de moitié.
Ça, c'est pas terrible.
Lorsqu'il y a beaucoup de soleil, vous
lirez difficilement sur l'écran de votre
smartphone.
Si vous voulez venir scroller et avoir de
la fluidité, le...
120Hz sera désactivé, vous resterez
uniquement en...
60Hz.
Vous n'aurez pas de...
5G mais uniquement de la
4G.
Pas de Always-On Display non plus.
Non, vous aurez un écran noir.
C'est dommage.
Il passera très rapidement en veille.
Il y aura un arrêt...
des tâches d'arrière-plan.
Donc il ne viendra pas récupérer vos
e-mails, vos messages, etcetera...
Vous aurez un iPhone bridé et avoir un
smartphone premium pour qu'il soit bridé,
c'est dommage.
Sauf si vous avez réellement besoin
d'avoir le maximum d'autonomie, si vous
allez faire un trek ou que sais-je encore
et que vous n'allez pas trouver une prise
électrique rapidement.
Pourquoi pas ?
Dans le cas contraire, on
évite de l'utiliser systématiquement.
Autre astuce en plus très importante,
pensez à nettoyer votre smartphone
rapidement.
Je ne veux pas dire le nettoyer au niveau
logiciel, mais le nettoyer physiquement.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'on a toujours son smartphone à
la main.
Toujours.
Dans les transports en commun, dans la
rue, chez des amis, chez vous.
Imaginez lorsque vous êtes par exemple
dans le métro...
Dans un bus, vous ouvrez la porte, vous
touchez à des choses, vous vous accrochez
à des barres pour vous tenir.
Et après, vous touchez votre smartphone.
Vous mettez des bactéries dessus.
Pire, lorsque vous êtes aux toilettes,
vous avez votre smartphone à la main.
Vous êtes toujours en train de toucher
votre smartphone.
Aujourd'hui, c'est un des objets les plus
sales qu'on a en permanence avec soi, même
le soir avant d'aller se coucher.
Pensez à le nettoyer régulièrement, non
pas que des produits qui vont
l'endommager.
Faites attention.
Vous pouvez prendre un produit pour les
vitres, ça conviendra parfaitement bien.
Pensez sérieusement à le nettoyer
régulièrement pour éviter les problèmes.
Quand on sait que son smartphone est très
très sale, on n'a pas envie.
Autre astuce très importante sur son
iPhone, pensez à activer les sauvegardes
sur iCloud.
Parce que si votre smartphone finit par
décéder à cause d'un mauvais usage, si
vous l'avez cassé, pire, on vous l'a
volé.
Vous serez très heureux de retrouver vos
sauvegardes quelque part dans le cloud.
Lorsque vous achèterez un nouvel iPhone
et bien vous le réinstallerez directement
sans difficulté.
Et ça c'est extrêmement important.
C'est juste une case à cocher.
Vous allez dans
iCloud, vous allez dans "sauvegarder mon
iPhone" et vous cochez cette case, ici,
tout de suite.
Comme ça vous serez tranquille.
Autre astuce importante, aujourd'hui, les
iPhones sont livrés sans chargeur.
Vous pouvez bien évidemment acheter un
chargeur sur le site d'Apple ou des
chargeurs compatibles.
Ils en vendent d'autres sur le site
d'Apple.
Il y a des marques sérieuses comme
Belkin, par exemple, mais il y en a
d'autres un peu douteuses, notamment
toutes les marques pas chères que vous
allez retrouver sur des sites comme
AliExpress.
Faites attention, achetez des marques
connues...
sérieuse, reconnue bien évidemment.
On va penser à acheter des chargeurs
Apple.
Ils sont totalement optimisés pour votre
iPhone.
Mais on peut utiliser des chargeurs de
marques concurrentes comme par exemple
Samsung, Oppo, OnePlus.
On ne fera pas des recharges à
67W, 120W etcetera...
On restera bridé à 20W ou 27W...
Il n'y a aucun problème ici parce que
votre iPhone va contrôler ce qui rentre
donc il n'y a pas de souci.
Mais des chargeurs de mauvaise qualité
risqueraient à terme d'endommager la
batterie de votre smartphone et ça on n'a
pas envie non plus.
Dernière astuce, n'utilisez pas n'importe
quel câble, aujourd'hui USB-C, avant
Lightning pour recharger votre iPhone.
Bien souvent, lorsqu'on va être dans un
hôtel, dans un Uber, ou que quelqu'un vous
donne un câble, on se dit « C'est
pratique, je me recharge ».
Faites attention où il est branché à
l'autre extrémité.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que des pirates pourraient
récupérer des informations de votre iPhone
que vous ne souhaiteriez pas leur donner.
Le câble de recharge envoie bien
évidemment un courant pour se recharger,
mais il envoie de la data.
Il l'envoie, il la récupère...
Si quelqu'un qui a une mauvaise intention
envers vous vous donne un câble, elle
pourra aspirer vos données.
Et ça, c'est pas terrible !
J'ai fait une vidéo sur les 7 erreurs qui
vous exposent aux hackers.
Allez la voir, vous deviendrez un
champion de la cybersécurité.
Ca c'est super bien !